If you want to hear a story about the height
of kleptocracy or maybe better said the depths
of cronyism currently in charge of our country.
This is the story for you. Donald Trump has
confirmed that he wants to host next year's
g seven summit at his own Doral Golf Club
in Miami, Florida. This would be completely
unconstitutional and this is not my opinion.
It's the opinion of legal and political experts
because there's this thing called the emoluments
clause asked why he wants to do this. This
is hilarious. Donald Trump said, well, it's
convenient because it's close to Miami airport.
Checkout a visibly sweaty, sniffing and confused.
Trump making the case for this after arguing
with a reporter about what counts as a question
and then making himself a martyr for willing
to be president of the United States. Take
a look.
Here we go. Yep. I actually have a question
for you on next year's g seven summit, but
can I just clarify something you said you
mentioned earlier today, one question go.
Let me do the clarification and then I'll
get to the question. You talked about calls
with China and a breaking news alert. I'm
trying to understand what specifically you
heard from China and on next year's [inaudible].
You alluded today drop several hens about
Miami, about drought and hosting next year's
g seven at your property. What reassurances,
if any, can you give the American people that
you are not looking to profit off the presidency?
Well, I'll tell you what I've spent and I
think I will. A combination of loss and opportunity
probably it'll cost me anywhere from three
to $5 billion to be precedent. And the only
thing I care about is this country couldn't
care less, otherwise I wouldn't have done
it.
People have asked me, what do you think it
costs and between opportunity, not doing thing.
I used to get a lot of money to make speeches.
Now he gives speeches all the time in order
to get Zippo. And that's good. And I did a
lot of great jobs and great deals that I don't
do anymore. And I don't want to do them because
the deals are making a great deals for the
country. And that's, to me, much more important.
Derail happens to be within Miami. It's a
city. It's a wonderful place. It's a very,
very successful area of Florida. Uh, it's
very importantly, only five minutes from the
airport, the airports right next door. It's
a big international airport, one of the biggest
in the world. Everybody that's calling all
of these people with all of their big entourages
come. Uh, it's set up. So PR, and by the way,
my people looked at 12 sites, all good, but
some were two hours from an airport, some
were four hours from Miami. They were so far
away. Uh, some didn't allow this, so they
didn't allow that. With arou. We have a series
of magnificent buildings. We call them
bungalows. They each hold from 50 to 70 very
luxurious rooms. Trump also very interested
in racking up mini bar revenue during the
[inaudible]. That's why he wants Russia back
in Putin's entourage. We'll show up to DRL
in the new g eight and they will just owe
Trump tons of money because of all the vodka
consumption. I mean, this is just so stupid
and so illegal, completely unconstitutional.
This would violate the emoluments clause against
a government official self enriching by virtue
of being in office. If Donald Trump was not
president, there would be no discussion of
holding a g seven at a Trump golf club. This
is a way in which Donald Trump is self enriching
by virtue of being president of the United
States or potentially self enriching. Trump
constantly sends signals to foreign officials
about where should they spend their money.
Trump has already wracked up endless violations
of the emoluments clause, and this would be
another one, and the thing with Trump is maybe
it's a good thing compared to corruption behind
closed doors, although there's plenty of that
with Trump.
With Trump, a lot of the corruption is out
in the open. I'm wondering, is it possible
that doing the corruption and the cronyism
out in the open helps Trump get away with
it in some way? If the g seven was that some
secret location and later it turned out that
it was Doral or Mar-a-lago, maybe that leads
to more outrage and consequences than Donald
Trump. Just saying straight up at my golf
club for all of the cow towering too and praying
to the altar of the constitution though I
would love to just hear Republicans say this
can't happen. This can't happen, but even
though they fetishize the constitution, it's
actually a lot like the Bible for them. We've
talked about how a lot of Republicans are
all about the Bible but not really. They're
all about the parts that are convenient for
them. Somethings something about abortion,
something, something about gay marriage because
man lying with another man or whatever.
Otherwise who cares when the Bible is not
convenient for you? They similarly claim to
be all about the constitution, but it's only
certain parts, right? The second amendment
and their complete misinterpretation of it
that they are definitely in favor of for sure.
The First Amendment for people they agree
with. Absolutely. The emoluments clause. That
sounds like something that should only apply
to democratic presidents, and I'll tell you
this, if Trump wants to do the g seven next
year at Doral or Mar-a-lago or whatever, he
will probably get away with it. The way it
will go down is will here, it's about to happen
for month after month after month, outrage
panels, debates. Then it will happen. Even
the legal experts say, Oh yeah, this is clearly
illegal. It'll be a week of corporate media
panels about, is this impeachable? Is it not
impeachable, blah, blah, blah legal experts.
Again, we'll continue to be United and say,
yeah, this is illegal. Then Trump will threatened
and you could tropical storm or something
and everybody will move on and forget about
it and he'll get away with it like he's gotten
away with everything else. Fiasco after fiasco,
cronyism, swamp filling worldwide. Embarrassments
the media outrage cycle chases it for their
own benefit and then we move on to something
else. When Trump says let's bomb a hurricane
or send people back to s hole countries or
whatever, and there's a very good chance,
I hate to tell you this, there's a good chance
this is not going to end in January of 2021
with the inauguration of a Democratic president.
There is a good chance and we need to recognize
it and we need to prepare mentally for it
cause I don't want to see the crying on November
whatever, 2020 if and when this happens, there's
a good chance this is going to go on until
January of 2025 when Donald Trump will be
78 years old and will be completing eight
years as president of the United States.
Be prepared. Buckle up it because it may well
be happening that, uh, is sort of the bulk
wrapping up our g seven coverage yesterday
and today. It has been an extraordinary embarrassment.
Half the country thinks that it was some major
alpha male victory of some kind for Donald
Trump. Uh, but anybody who understands sort
of how the world works and basic geopolitics
and diplomacy understands that this was truly
the height of embarrassment for our country.
Make sure you follow the David Pakman show
on Instagram, uh, at David Pakman show, we
will have a poll and other content related
to the [inaudible]. And while you're there,
follow me at David Dot. Pacman. I have posted
a video to my Instagram of a Portuguese dog.
Now, I don't mean a Portuguese water dog.
I'm not talking about the breed. I'm talking
about a dog from Portugal named [inaudible],
which means flee in Spanish or presumably
in Portuguese as well. I'm guessing, uh, who
watches the David Pakman show? Okay. There
is a Portuguese dog that watches the David
Pakman show daily
and I have a video of that dog on my Instagram
at David Dot. Patrick, follow me there. We'll
take a quick break, much, much more after
this